the granchester is always inviting the
best chess players on the planet this
year we have a very fun eclectic mix of
talent who are you most excited to play
and compete against i think the most
interesting will be the players who i'm
going to play against in the candidates
tournament which is my next classical
event after this one uh so farouza
we he's taken a break from
uh playing a short break from playing
chess i guess to prepare very seriously
for the candidates so we haven't seen
him over the board in some time he's
also one of the hottest players in the
world for the last you know year or so
so it'll be very interesting to play
against ali reza
against janna
of course as well he's also playing in
the kansas tournament
ravport also playing in the candidates
tournament so there's a lot of guys here
who are
who are playing there which will be very
interesting to see how their form is
coming into that tournament
in general i'm always looking forward to
compete against everyone but of course
we have a newcomer
at least on the full schedule of the
grand chess tour he happens to be to be
french as well
to be playing really well so of course
so i think
it's going to be an interesting match up
i'm looking forward to to see our
efforts
i don't want to say any places and
special because for me all players is
very good
[Music]
i think it's an
amazing tournament i'm very happy to be
here
i think all the players are great and i
really if i want to be honest and
i would like to i'm looking forward to
play all of them because they are all
very great players
and
i think it would be great
tournament
ah not really i think the whole the
whole uh lineup in general it's very
challenging and
it's very nice for me to to be a part of
the granchester as a regular player i
mean i had the invitation before but
just for one or two events oh i really
look
forward to play
against fabiano
i've lost to him and the american cup so
i want to have my revenge yeah really i
can't name one person maybe shakir i
like to play with him he plays a
very interesting chess and
yeah also like you know uh i have a very
bad score against him so
maybe that's why i don't know so i'm
interested to see how fabiano is doing i
think he's working very hard for
candidates also we have ali restaurant
who i believe is only
18 i think it's turning 19
if i remember correctly in a few months
so it's number three in the world right
now i guess the one who i'm looking
forward to compete is not participating
this year but
every player is
is really fine here and
despite we have
mcdonald here participating with us i
think it's also will be very very
challenging
[Music]